okay quick show of hands who has met
either by reading it or tutoring or
whatever form who's met this idea before
heads straight up yeah a small number
okay great that's fine okay for mostly
I'm just going to treat this as if
you've never seen a cooker okay so
hopefully that will mix it what about X
clinics is an abbreviation okay it's
short for conic sections which then this
is the natural question what a conic
sections okay if you had to guess just
up the name what do you think a conic
section is a section of a cone is a good
guess
okay so to put a little more detail on
that I would say it's a cross section
now there are many different kinds of
cross sections of cones and that's what
this topic is about the idea being you
can take this shape and by slicing
across it in different ways for instance
let's just slice across it right across
you know right straight there okay what
kind of shape would you get or you get a
circle
what are you okay so a circle is a kind
of conic section what kind of cutting
okay yeah a circle is not the only one
is actually a whole variety other than
that's what this topic in about now the
first kind of conic section I want us to
look at is actually what that limb she
was about okay I'm thinking out that
parabola because I think we're most
familiar with it as it relates to
clinics so can we remember well where's
the first time that you meet the
parabola you know by the actual shape
when is the first time you mean it
I got radium
you know yeah what what relevance does
it have what topic does a common thief
back long time ago probably quadratics
I hope okay so the idea is that the
parabola is a shape okay
now you might want to actually destroy
yourself a small parabola because it's
conceptual ideas about it the parabola
is a shade okay so it's a piece of
geometry it's a visual representation
sorry
um all an algebraic idea that make sense
geometry algebra here in geometry
here's the algebra okay when you've got
something when you have a polynomial at
its degree is two so that's all
algebraic talk okay when you have that
you get this kind of shape when you
graph the function they should avoid
this kind of curvature and so a circle
okay
Bellagio we developed a third up okay we
noticed that you do notice that you can
get the parabola as a shape from a
totally different idea right not
thinking about quadratics at all how did
you consider we're way we define the
parabola how do we define but had
nothing to do with quadratics given life
sorry set against the parameters set
10100 pros okay so we thought about the
parametric definition so we said what's
the standard coordinates for a parabola
for X or Y in terms of let's call it P
for parameter what do we have up for our
values to remember to AP it's very good
so you consider it as a parametric
representation now that is different
it's still kind in the same vein isn't
it okay like it's still the same
quadratic idea it's just sort of dressed
up with another another variable we also
considered it as and I wonder if you
actually you know got up and did this
visualizer Marshall how your tie
previously we visualize it as the set of
all points or the center points that
move if you remember that kind of
definition that are all related to a
particular point and a particular line
okay now we gave those two features
important is remember what they were was
the point it was the focus and the line
was there good okay so what was the
relationship between the focus the
directrix and a parabola what was the
thing that connected all of them good
okay so I have no idea how well I'm draw
this pretty badly actually but if I took
a point like say this one okay the idea
is that any of these points right the
thing that unifies all of them is if you
draw a line from there to the focus and
from there to the directrix obviously
perpendicular okay that distance should
be the same
okay so there's a geometric definition
what did the algebra look like what are
the coordinates what was it so was the
name of the focus I had a letter usually
s s the focus nothing s call the
directions D okay that makes sense right
we'll call this point P good coordinate
XY right so we would have said a log is
definition in your scene you're probably
writing this down right we would have
said
yes it was a date yes this is ringing
bells okay now before I move and
progress from there and that should give
you an example right I just want you to
notice that I can write this this is the
Waqas definition of
right this is a slightly different way
okay you get to that in a second what is
um what's the reason why I'm saying the
parabola okay because you understand it
well but also because there's something
about the parabola and how relates to
say I told you that a circle was a conic
section before right I could cut this in
another way not to get a parabola have a
look at it have a look at the cone what
we might you cut it in order to get a
parable it kind of shape out of it
any ideas there's lots of different ways
any suggestion I see a lot of you're
making versions with your hands how
would you articulate it verbally what
kind of cut are you going to make kind
of slice how is it different for
instance to this slice yeah
the site okay let's go with that
the start on that okay would it be
parallel to the pause side okay
items a good start I think you're
referring to this thing here we have a
name for this don't we it's actually the
slant idea so powerless a in fact it's
perfect okay if we are doing rather if
we went through it like this okay what
kind of shape would you get the answer
is yes you would get a parabola or
slightly off okay now we're going to
look at the other kinds of shapes that
there are here's the important thing I
want to get across to you they all seem
to come from this one geometric idea
take a 3d shape slice it to get a are 2d
plane across it and then you get all
these different shapes now the fact that
they're geometrically similar what that
suggests there's some kind of I wonder
if you've caught me talking about this
closely there's some kind of algebraic
relationship between this is a geometric
relationship there ought to be an
algebraic one as well okay because
they're sort of like suicidal the same
coin just appear from different angles
now here's what the algebraic
relationship is I'm going to rewrite
this and it's going to be mind-blowing
ly complicated okay watch this okay step
back course I know that takes a while
for taking even for you guys okay what
am I done all I've done is divided by
this perpendicular distance okay the
reason it's important though is it's
drawing attention to the fact that the
Walker this isn't just this it was that
the locus is a particular kind of ratio
namely the ratio between the distance to
the focus of the set s and the distance
to the directrix okay
that ratio is everything okay that ratio
is the algebraic feature that sort of
binds all of these conic sections
together okay it's so important that it
gets a whole new name it's called
eccentricity now being that it starts
with an E they call it which is a big
deal or like we just talked about this
morning right that is its own special
constant and it's used all the time it's
a big deal to put two things on one
letter but there you go so the way I
would say it is the eccentricity of this
parabola actually eccentricity of all
parabolas is 1 ok so that begs the
question what happens when you change
the eccentricity or something okay well
we're going to get to that question in